studying the past human what worked
before because then you can be better
prepared for the present and you can get
wealthier in the future you can learn
and you can make money from anywhere in
the world learn what you love and focus
on it don't work for somebody else's
dream we're all human we all make
mistakes we all learn he's an American
penny stock trader and entrepreneur he's
best known for earning four million
dollars by day trading while at
university between two twelve thousand
four hundred and fifteen dollars bar
mitzvah gifts into one point six five
million dollars by the time he was 21 by
day trading penny stocks
he's Timothy Sykes and here are his top
ten rules to success and as always guys
as you're watching the videos if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
to other people can be inspired as well
also as you are writing something down
it's much more likely to stick in your
head to enjoy
hey Tim Sykes millionaire mentor and
trader here with my 10 key to success
check this place out
we're here in Cambodia I know it's kind
of a weird place to do a little
educational video but Evan Carmichael
had me on his channel so I'm going to
give him viewers my 10 keys for success
number one study the past we're here in
Cambodia we're looking at it is
beautiful but we're also learning from
the past for me I study the stock market
and my top students study the stock
market the key to success in the stock
market is not just finding hot picture
you know breaking news it's studying the
past seeing what works before because
then you can be better prepared for the
present and you can get wealthier in the
future rule number 2 key for success
keep an open mind I know many of you
guys would never come to a place like
Cambodia it's hot I'm sweating right I'm
eating like weird food my stomach wasn't
feeling that great but I keep an open
mind because life is all about exploring
it's not just about financial gain it's
about growing your brain and your
knowledge and experience that's what I
love see the success for number three
let's see I would say planning but I'm
not very good at planning I would say
just going with the flow and just you
know being open to different things I
didn't plan on making this video but
Evan was nice enough to make a little
video about me and I wanted to do
something in return so I'm going with it
I'm here in Cambodia
tomorrow I'm actually going to the
Philippines but freaking love it I'll
make a video from anywhere cute a
success number four you can learn and
you can make money from anywhere in the
world we're at a very unique time in
history right now you have the internet
you're watching me I'm not necessarily
watching you but I can communicate with
you I can leave comments we can go back
and forth we can interact that was
impossible just a few decades ago this
new technology has opened up a whole new
world of Education and interaction take
advantage of it don't get left out don't
just watch a few YouTube videos use
everything use Twitter use Facebook use
snapchat use Pinterest use Instagram all
this social media helps you get a lot
more connected number 5 use social media
get your name out there
get your wisdom out there if you're an
expert
anything you can make a lot of money you
can find a lot of success you don't just
have to be a doctor or a lawyer anymore
there's so much money in the world
there's so much interest and there's so
many people and so many interesting
subjects all you have to do is be
open-minded that's kind of what I am
remember six for success don't you take
the traditional route I know a lot of
older people your parents your
grandparents think that success has to
be down like a very certain like narrow
hallway when in fact success is
everything the world is fantastic I've
been fortunate to visit over a hundred
plus countries I've met so many
different people and experience
different cultures we're a lot more
similar than a lot of people think that
we are you know we're all human we're
all in this great experience and journey
together
number seven I would say I'm trying to
keep this you know very general and very
open to everybody um I would say focus
on what you love you know I love to
travel I love to eat I love to trade
stocks I love to teach I love to get my
message out there now through social
media and just learn what you love and
focus on it don't work for somebody
else's dream because no matter how much
money you're making or how successful
you are you're not focusing on yourself
and you have to be a little selfish in
this life you have to do what you love
and figure out what you love number
eight study study study so that you
really understand yourself better study
a whole multitude of different subjects
and see wait a minute what are you
interested in what's going to like
really piqued your interest I was a
philosophy major in college all my
friends were Business and Finance but I
took a philosophy class and I was like
wow I like thinking outside the box I
like how this you know makes me feel I'm
not a very good philosopher I was
actually like the worst one in the class
he's got any smoke weed and I actually
care about money but at least I learned
and now because of my philosophical
teachings I kind of have a little bit of
a different education that I bring to
the stock market and now the teaching
wells and frankly that's why I have so
much success number nine focus on your
long-term goals I know we live in a
world full of instant gratification and
you want money now you
Fame now you want success now but if you
want true success it's going to take not
just days weeks or months not talking
about like going viral and being some
viral sensation or being like some kid
star or if you have like an amazing
voice or something I'm sorry about great
laughing success over the course of your
life it's a journey and it's going to
take years if not decades and you're
going to have up and you're going to
have down and you have to respect your
entire journey it's not just about where
you end up it's not just about the
success that you achieve at the end it's
the whole experience that's life that's
the beauty of it
number 10 do not be afraid of making
mistakes do not be afraid of failure or
if you're a soft trader like me law okay
some of my biggest losses have helped
mold me and they helped to develop me
into a better trader into a better
teacher obviously they suck but again
we're all human we all make mistakes we
all learn and lessons that we learn from
our losses and our mistakes and that we
take into the future that helps us make
us better so don't just ignore these
lessons phones just try to pretend that
you're perfect don't sweep Worcester's
under the rug rule number one for me in
the stock market is cut losses quickly
that's only because I've taken several
big losses in my career and I never want
that feeling again so now it's made me a
more conservative trader in future and I
was very angry with those losses at
first now I'm very grateful for them I
appreciate the entire journey and I want
you to also these are my 10 keys to
success I'm going to go continue
exploring more of Cambodia and Angkor
Wat and Angkor Thom and buy own and all
these amazing places the world is a
beautiful place you're capable of
anything
ignore the negativity embrace positivity
let's live
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Chris asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
it's in with these states that had the
biggest impact on you and why what are
you going to take from this and
immediately apply to your life or your
business leaving the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Ronda young Ronda thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book here one
word and for entering in the book
contest that we had last month I really
really really appreciate your support so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is let's love I'll see you
soon
yeah I'm not professional at all I'm
just real this is an important lesson be
real be honest don't be afraid of making
mistakes don't be afraid of showing who
you truly are I know there's a lot of
people think like oh you have to wear
like a fancy tie and suit all the time
and you can't make mistakes and you have
to be so prepared for everything that's
not realistic okay the more real you are
the better you'll do in whatever field
you are we're all human okay
kindness doesn't take over the world for
another few decades so for right now
we're all that here where the kings and
queens of this world so just act human
and you might be surprised at how people
react to you you start to look what can
I do to get happy it's not just about
money it's about you know
self-sufficiency and finding yourself
and for me it's not you know I took
twelve thousand on now at four point
five million in trading profits that's
cool but the journey along the way
helped me find myself and build myself
and I chose not to work on Wall Street
but to travel all over the world because
I love that personally try different
stuff but see how it feels yeah I want
more people thinking like scientists
like testing testing testing refining
refining or finding but you got to break
the rat rice rat race cycle where it's
like money is going to solve everything
it won't yeah you know I teach how to
make money that's you know it's kind of
contradictory some people are like well
why do you focus on flexibility on
freedoms your lives exactly you need to
get everything you need to get out of
you know working for somebody else's
dreams so if you have a little savings
or some money then you're working on
your own dream right right exactly why
do you think he was so good at investing
at first I was actually trying to invest
in big companies but my portfolio wasn't
really moving so I gravitated towards
lower price stocks any stocks and that
really got my accounts moving they're
more volatile they're riskier but
they're simpler they usually have one or
two products you know so they're either
going to succeed big or fail big so what
I try and do is ride the momentum for a
few days or a few hours when they
announce good news the big partnership
or something like that and I make my
money grow like you were talking about
earlier you know trying to make $10 or
$100 I've so I keep it simple and I'm
always focused on the big goal at the
end but I'm taking small profits along
the way the two
to be successful is to work harder than
other people because everybody wants
success
everybody wants the Lamborghini
everybody wants freedom but what are you
willing to do to get there that's my
question to you you know we're here at
the most prestigious university in
America Harvard fantastic very honored
thank you for having me here the people
who have gotten here have worked their
butts off to get here but that's just
the beginning whether you're in college
here
of going to go to college or you're out
of college this is a lifelong journey
where you have to continually work hard
work harder than other people to get
ahead a lot of people give up at
different times I'm no longer at that
stage you know when I had my big loss I
basically gave up for a year I was in
the gutter but I came back and I said
you know what this was a mistake that I
made investing it wasn't the pattern I
didn't go against what I had learned to
make all my millions before this loss I
invested and I didn't do my full due due
diligence and that was my mistake
I eventually got back into trading I saw
more patterns and I became a number one
lane trader at a 50,000 unco vector in
2007 to 2011